so a while ago I got a question from one
of my fans Mohammed who's asking me do I
start a business around something that
I'm passionate about or something i
think i can make a lot of money with and
I said instead of answering this I'm
going to throw it out to you guys my
YouTube audience I challenge you to
answer the question for Mohammad as me
and a lot of you did in the comments and
and some of them were hilarious was
great and some of you went the extra
mile and made a video and a lot of them
cracked me up some of them were serious
some of them are hilarious and so what
follows is the best of youtube fans
copying me modeling me channeling me
answering Muhammad's question joy my
daddy's newsletter welcome to believe
nation I'm Evan Carmichael I got this
great question i was listening to salsa
music with my collar popped up eating
breakfast when i got a YouTube question
love you guys and this question comes
from Mohammed who asks should I start a
business that I'm passionate about but
may not be practical may not be making a
lot of money or should I start a
business that I think we'll be
successful and we'll we'll make a lot of
money this is a great question and the
one that a lot of entrepreneurs
struggled with my answer to him is you
have to love what you do you have to
love what you do being an entrepreneur
is really hard everyone at some point is
trying to figure it out what do I do
with my life you gotta do what is right
for you what you feel is the best thing
to do Mohammed you've heard this before
build it and they will come if you're
passionate about it if you love it if
you think this is the thing that's
driving you to do it then you know what
there's people out there waiting for you
to create this business it's important
to make money and I would love for you
to make a lot of money but the thing is
that it should be around helping people
and it should be around something that
you love to do what's going to get you
through the night you gotta believe
because I don't have a shirt you have a
shirt this is believe I don't have
you have to think from your heart not
from your head from your heart do it
don't use your logical mind because you
think it's going to be successful or
wealth but you don't have your heart and
you're just gonna do it like a job it
may not come out because you can't
really create something great if you
don't have passion for it you can't you
can't make a big difference you can't
change the world if you don't have
passion the secret to success is to
combine your passions and keep adding
value through them have a business you
love and grow it don't let any limiting
belief or little man stop you if you're
doing this just for the money you're
never gonna make it the thing is that a
lot of intrapreneurs just start a
business in order to make a lot of money
and most of them go broke but any
business can make money if there are
providing value to their customers but
you are not going to stick with it if
you're just doing it for the money
you're not going to stick with it if you
don't really love it if you look at any
successful entrepreneur they didn't do
it for the money they didn't because
they have passion for something and they
built their business around that passion
steve said you have to trust that the
dots will somehow connect in your future
do it go with it and the way will be
shown to you things will work out for
you everything that you need will come
together and will work out and who knows
that thing that's unpractical they
become really practical may become
really doable and will become successful
and will make you rich and then you'd
end off with this big high note and
you'd look straight into camera and
you'd say you know if you're gonna do
this you gotta do that I believe in you
I believe that you as an entrepreneur
can live your passion live your dream
all you have to do is believe thanks for
watching please like the media and
subscribe to the channel to see more
videos thanks so much for watching and
see you soon and if you want some
believe every week in your inbox to
motivate you check out the link below to
join my newsletter I have a question for
you all I want you to help me I've got
these flowers and they
been kind of withering away and I'm just
wondering is do you know of a better way
in which I can invigorate these flowers
if you do leave a comment leave a
comment I want to know oh you make this
look easy don't you uh stuff it'll not
baby if you want more entrepreneur
goodness check out the link to my
newsletter below see you there
you